d'amour c'était aussi le thème de la
comédie musicale hair créée il ya 30 ans
tout juste en pleine vague hippie
souvenez-vous à l'époque que tout le
monde sait mais aujourd'hui la comédie
musicale a été revu corrigé et reprise
au théâtre mogador à paris stéphane
haumant philippe châtain let the
sunshine in laisse entrer le soleil
l'hymne de toute une génération autant
l'on croyait au pouvoir des fleurs et à
l'amour universel
l'adaptation française a attiré 1
million de spectateurs révélé julien
clerc et gérard lenorman en rompant avec
les spectacles traditionnels
au final tout le monde monte sur scène
le public était convié à monter sur
scène et je peux vous dire que j'ai vu
des personnages qui eux mêmes ne pensait
pas une seconde
participer au spectacle comme ils l'ont
fait les gens font des généralement avec
avec les acteurs
les temps changent et la partition de r
a été rafraîchi avec du rap du funk de
la soul
depuis trente ans on remonte toujours
air de la même façon le moi j'ai eu
envie de prendre la partition et de la
regarder avec un regard neuf races en 97
les bourgeois porte robe de soirée ou
smoking et les hippies dénoncent les
dangers de la drogue
autant du sida plus question de vente et
l'amour libre air a perdu en provocation
et suscite des avis partagés
il ne s'agit d'une marche pour moi donc
tout marche bien ça n'a plus rien à voir
avec ce traité en s'offrant retraite
oui plutôt oui parce que toutes les
questions que les remises en question
sont la société sont complètement et
d'une corée minimiser
reste les refrains paix d'amour et les
mélodies si facile à reprendre en choeur
en se tenant par la main tous ensemble
comme au bon vieux temps
à